I've never seen real Indian news but I'm
ready for it I've never seen an Indian
TV news channel before it looks just
like a normal news broadcast I here we
go I'm just gonna I'm just gonna dive
into this thing you see don't be stupid
no I'm not honestly nothing I'm not
being stupid be nice don't be stupid
dr. Subramanyam is killing it right now
he's bringing the heat you're an
ignorant man who call them ignorant um
I'm just gonna refer to him as dr.
Subaru because when I see SUV that's
just a word that I think of it's just
like where's the Comedy Central Roast
Henry don't every line you just called
him Dumbo is actually how like we all
did it first grade where like someone
else is talking you like their argument
so you're like talk over them he must
have said liar at least 150 times it's
like they remixed it this could be a
viral song or something so dr. Subaru's
is regulating one two three four other
people like the host is now instigating
the fight it's just chaos you could just
keep throwing people in this screen and
dr. Subaru would just utterly destroy I
don't even know what they're talking
about is this news I'm in love with dr.
Zuber I wish that he were my dad
stressing me out
they've called each other liars for four
minutes right now the one dude is still
silent just sorta sitting I don't think
even knows he's on camera I just figured
out that the guy in the far right is
actually made of wax so he's not a real
person he's seen like other countries
news and knows this is like a farce it's
just like yeah I wish I wish we had like
actual stories and report on it's over
now it didn't end they just stopped the
video because it kept going like you
think there'd be a producer in the booth
to like cut this guy's mic at some point
show the squirrel waterskiing let's just
cut to that it seems pretty similar to
American politics if American
politicians said how they really felt I
don't like it it's much more
entertaining than American news program
I think we need to get dr. Subaru over
here ASAP
I totally watch American news if it was
like this I mean this is India this is
India right here and it's it's it's
spirit force which one got a degree from
Harvard does it Swami please I'll say it
Swami shut them up
Swami got a degree Swami's loud Scott
the degree from Harvard oh my god Swami
why